voilà vingt-deux jours que les adjoints
de la chaîne a lot où la responsabilité
de la commune et de ses projets le gros
dossier de l'extension de l'école
avec chaufferie bois qui va chauffer
tous les abattements communaux qui a
donc été entamées sous le mandat de
madame le maire et qui doit être
poursuivie actuellement mais tant que
brigitte l'ine est porté disparu la
mairie ne peut pas plus avancé les
adjoints n'ont pas le droit de se lancer
dans de nouveaux projets c'est inédit
c'est inédit après si compliqué je
pourrais pas vous dire si à long terme
comment ça se passera on sait pas du
tout et puis c'est surtout la reprise
des débats
réorganisation en tout cas de l'exécutif
de la mairie qui
opposera dire question en fait pour cet
habitant qui a lancé une cagnotte en
soutien à la famille de brigitte ligne
et cette disparition est un choc mais au
moins les 10400 10 euros qu'il a
récoltés aideront à rembourser les frais
engagés par la recherche savoir qu'un
clash note est quand même un village
très très solidaire donc
là on pouvait pas rester comme ni on
pouvait pas rester impuissants ici à
9000 kilomètres la solution qu'on a
trouvée pour revenir en et c'est cette
année comme cet élan de solidarité
il est à la hauteur de l'investissement
de brigitte ligne est à la fois pour sa
commune et pour ses habitants je vais
quand même pas ce que c'était pas une
mais reste c'était une amie ont discuté
avec est assez facilement dans village
cerexhe tf1 un maire très investi dans
cette commune nous qui a été investi
pour nos travaux pour la chaîne notre
terrain enfin pour tous donc ça fait un
peu bizarre de plus pas de se dire qu'on
la verra plus quoi la famille de
brigitte ligne a décidé de mettre un
terme aux recherches mais à 9000
kilomètres de la chaîne a lot à la
réunion des centaines de personnes
continuent de se mobiliser sur un compte
facebook dans l'espoir de la retrouver